on July 10th 2014 police officers in
Coffee County Georgia entered a private
yard where six children were playing the
officers who were in pursuit of a
criminal suspect ordered the kids to get
facedown on the ground when the family
dog came out into the yard one of the
officers fired at the dog twice but
missed one of those bullets struck a
ten-year-old in the back of his knee
when the child's mother attempted to sue
the officer for damages the case was
dismissed due to qualified immunity a
legal doctrine that effectively shields
police from most civilian lawsuits
following the police killing of George
Floyd and growing calls for police
accountability this once obscure
doctrine has been thrust into the
national spotlight qualified immunity
immunity more people are starting to
look around and take notice
what's gone wrong with policing today
and are asking you know gee is the fact
that the police officers are officially
above the law maybe that's part of the
problem
William bode is a professor at the
University of Chicago and the author of
a widely cited paper arguing that
qualified immunity should be overturned
qualified immunity is a judge-made
doctrine but says that when you sue a
government official for violating the
Constitution you can't get anything you
can't get any recovery or any damages
even if they did something
unconstitutional unless they also did
something that was clearly
unconstitutional or if the court has has
put the test you can only recover
damages against an officer who was
plainly incompetent or who knowingly
violated the law incompetence or that an
officer acted illegally on purpose is
difficult to prove in court and there
were many examples of individuals
clearly harmed by police error but
unable to collect damages because
specific issues of a case hadn't yet
been clearly established as
unconstitutional in a previous case one
case is thrown out because of the
difference between unleashing a police
dog to bite a motionless suspect in a
pushy ravine and unleashing a police dog
to bite a compliant suspect in a canal
in the woods if you or I or any normal
person is accused of violating the law
and we say oh I didn't realize it was
illegal or you know I knew this was a
gray area but I thought I could kind of
skate by that's not an excuse you know
there's an old adage ignorance of the
law is no excuse and the one group of
people from it is an excuse are the
government officials would enforce the
law who'd think should be held more
account
if anything our actually trained in the
law and should know what they aren't
supposed to do this sweeping protection
was never voted on or signed into law
but was instead created over decades of
judicial actions to give government
officials room to make judgment calls
without fear of lawsuits in 1871
Congress passes the Civil Rights statute
that we still have today the Ku Klux
Klan act vas statute doesn't say
anything about immunity it says that
when a government official a state
official violates their constitutional
rights you can sue them for damages a
hundred years later in 1967 Chief
Justice Earl Warren decides the statute
doesn't quite mean what it says and that
there was a kind of unwritten defense
that sort of preempts the statute and
provides these kinds of defenses and in
1982 in a case called Harlow versus
Fitzgerald they announced the modern
qualified immunity test which says you
can only sue a police officer if they
violate clearly established law then the
sort of forty years since then I've been
a drip of maybe 30 or 40 cases where the
court makes the test a little bit harder
every time
and makes it really hard to find
anything to be really established law so
because this is a judge-made doctrine
the court can fix that anytime they can
they could step in and say oh actually
we you know made a mistake and the
doctrine shouldn't be here or we've gone
a little bit too far and we need to make
more clear that isn't supposed to be
impossible to recover but Congress can
also fix it so because it's just an
interpretation of a statute that
Congress wrote Congress also has the
power to step in at any time and try to
either change the doctrine or repeal it
entirely weeks after the killing of
George Floyd revitalized the criminal
justice reform movement the Supreme
Court dealt a blow to reformers by
declining to here a set of cases
questioning the constitutionality of
qualified immunity
meaning that currently the only hope for
quick reform is legislation like the
bill co-sponsored by libertarian
congressman Justin Amash I've been
concerned for sure are they concerned
about our drug laws and qualified
immunity is just another example of a
justice system that is not working for
people
the current qualified immunity bill
proposed by representative Amash would
basically eliminate the doctrine entire
and it's a little bit awkward to think
about how do you pass a bill to get rid
of a judge-made doctrine because the
doctor is already not in the bill so
what do you do pass an empty page that
just doesn't contain the doctrine that
already wasn't there that doesn't work
so the bill just adds a paragraph to the
civil rights statutes saying it shall
not be a defense that the police officer
was acting in good faith it shall not be
a defense the police officer did not
know his conduct was lawful shall not be
a defense that the conduct though
unconstitutional was not clearly
unconstitutional it just sort of names
what the doctrine of qualified immunity
is and says no most congressional
support is coming from Democrats I don't
think there's any reason for it to be a
partisan issue I think you know if
there's anything we still all agree on
it's things like the rule of law and
government officials obey the
Constitution as long as that have
hopeful that people will will come
around to that basic idea the White
House recently called broad qualified
immunity reform a non-starter a stance
Attorney General William bar has
defended I don't think you need to
reduce immunity to go after bad cops
because that would resolve certainly in
police pulling back it's no policing is
the toughest job in the country what we
ought to do but the fact that government
officials have to make hard decisions is
think carefully about what legal rules
what constitutional rules we want to
restrain them and then try to figure out
how to train them and make them obey
those rules rather than make a bunch of
rules and then decide we don't care when
the rules are violated
I don't think reforming or even
abolishing qualified immunity is gonna
change all the problems we have with
policing in this country you know
there's a lot of research that police
unions are another huge part of the
problem because they make it really hard
to hold bad apples accountable even if
we all know who the bad apples are and
then of course there's a serious
argument that it's not just about bad
apples that there's much bigger
structural problem with the way we
license the use of violence against our
own citizens so qualified immunity is
not going to fix all of that it will
make it easier to correct individual
constitutional abuses to make sure
courts are are actually part of the
conversation rather than just sort of
ignoring the whole thing and I do hope I
could be wrong with this but I do hope
that by creating the sense that that the
police are not above the law that it
could sort of lead to some of the bigger
cultural changes we probably need
you